non-minimalists
any advice i haven't asked for is bad
advice that's where i wanted to start
or an hour plus into the podcast and
we're just getting started
that was the intro y'all all right so
any advice i haven't asked for is bad
advice so
let's talk about that that's a re that's
a rewording almost of what you said
all advice is flawed advice which i i
think is a great
um is a great maxim
i have that essay here i'll put a link
to it in the show i'm not going to read
the whole thing but it's about the
advice
epidemic and what what
lisa's really saying is hey i didn't ask
for your advice
but we are so caught up in giving it
right so the beginning of this essay
starts out like this
the urge to convince others is
overwhelming on the surface it appears
virtuous to help to instruct to coach
to guide to motivate giving advice
gives the impression of nobility as is
as if we have an
obligation to ameliorate the plight of
the world
to assist people headed the wrong way
to point them in the right direction we
are all
middlemen in the middle of a self-help
epidemic
just look at social media overnight
experts espousing advice
you should wake up early you shouldn't
eat that you should embrace
chains change you shouldn't get anxious
you should change your habits you
shouldn't wear socks with sandals
um so here's the thing except for the
last piece of advice
yeah that one's pretty good actually
let's let's be honest
although all the cool kids now are
wearing socks of sandals i think
dude they are i'm just teasing and so
here's the thing
uh what lisa you're saying is
yeah it's not appropriate to tell other
people what to try to convince them we
hate being convinced
and when you look at the most
stereotypical examples of that
the used car salesman or the
telemarketer
or when you're walking through a mall
years ago remember i remember the
contracts we used to sign when i did the
leases at malls
when we leased a kiosk there's a clause
in those contracts because of
uh the obnoxious sales people it's
called a no barking clause
do you know what that means so you know
when you're walking past like a a
t-mobile kiosk at the dayton mall hey
look
do you have this pamphlet hey what kind
of cell phone you have right that's
barking
barking yeah and so they have a whole
claws in there because people were
getting turned off and they
didn't want to keep walking through the
mall because people were
trying to convince them they're getting
barked up that is
the pandemic that preceded the pandemic
we're in now it's the advice pandemic
i was looking up quotes on bad advice
and i'm gonna i have to paraphrase it
because i can't remember it directly but
it said something along the lines of
most people are dissatisfied with their
decisions because they take their advice
from salespeople
that's good yeah did you enjoy this
video
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalists private podcast
available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists today